no one was prepared for what happened
corridor crew we've removed your channel
from youtube literally if you if you
click on it right now it just goes to
this monkey holding the magnifying glass
this might be one of the few times we'll
ever google search corridor crew and not
be able to click on anything
does this mean we're technically
unemployed as of this moment
it's just a normal day in the office
thursday morning usually that's our day
to film react so i come into the office
sit down at the desk
as i log in i type in my password your
password was changed less than an hour
ago i hadn't been on the light at all so
i was a little confused but typed it in
a few more times your password was
changed an hour ago your password was
changed an hour ago
immediately i hit up our rit guy kim on
discord christian calls me and he goes
and then he says hey maybe maybe
somebody got it got it to his account
someone has changed his password on his
google account so he immediately booted
that guy out and uh had me change my
password right good thing we caught that
early we start setting up for react
about 10 minutes later i get another
message from christian saying hey i see
a message that we've been hacked can you
check on this and that's when my heart
sank we start getting notifications
from all over the world fans telling us
you better look at your channel we look
on the channel and i didn't even
recognize it the corridor crew channel
is not the corridor crew channel it is
now called micro strategy as a new
banner a new profile picture and it had
no videos except a single live stream
that had been going on for one hour this
is about the worst case scenario a
youtuber can ever imagine the news
spread like wildfire across the studio
this is the whole goddamn channel this
is our livelihood has this ever happened
before no no no not not on this scale
the first thought is are the videos
still there someone just has their
finger over the delete button and it's
completely up to them if they want to
just remove all your hard work and all
the team's hard work from years and
years ago i immediately jumped to
instagram and twitter just so they had
an update from our voice
all right guys we know we were hacked
what happened
we did it we finally got hacked yeah we
finally did it yes we found it so hard
and we finally figured out so big that
we got hacked it was encouraging to have
so many people backing us in that moment
you know so many people who immediately
stopped what they were doing and alerted
us to something that was going on
instead of sitting back and just kind of
enjoying the chaos of it there's a name
of the guy like we have the name of the
guy who's live streaming we know who it
is we're all logged in we're all
watching this live stream and we're all
thinking who the heck is this michael
sailor guy he apparently left the
company that he was at that the
channel's name was changed too he left
that company like a week ago and when
you look him up one of the first things
that people also ask is how much money
has michael saylor lost michael saylor
the chief executive of microstrategy
will step down following a 917 million
dollar loss on bitcoin investments whoa
what the heck if you're committing a
crime you don't like you don't murder
somebody and then leave your head shot
really interesting strategy whoever has
posted this live stream right now
this video of this person is has also
been stolen and is using to push a like
crypto scam we quickly realized that no
matter who this michael sailor character
is it doesn't matter
he was not the hacker but we need him
off our channel and we need him off our
channel now is anyone else logged in
here still on the channel because since
i still am i could theoretically like
cut the live stream and change the
password and do like a four sign out of
all the accounts i'm just gonna quickly
cut that live stream michael saylor
keeps talking and the more he talks the
more i'm interested the guy has a way
with words and honestly he's making a
lot of sense i'm there taking notes like
i do i'd already logged on to my crypto
accounts and i was preparing to transfer
the money to make 10x on the spot and
sam cuts the feed without even asking
it's like this is my channel too to it
to a lesser extent i guess legally to no
extent but
i really wanted to make some money
even with the live stream cut off we
still have a lot of work ahead where did
he come from how did he get in and does
he still have access in order to do more
damage the crew channel you can review
the logins and like the only fresh login
from the last month was just now when i
signed in highly confusing so it doesn't
say there's any recent sign-ins we don't
know where this is coming from man that
means that somebody utilized one of our
computers yeah that's why i thought it
was parsec at first maybe we can see if
somebody went into christian's computer
or something i started going through all
the logs and our sect was clear nobody
did anything computers are all good
nobody did anything and then i go and
look at christian's email and then we
check the logs and then i see it a login
from another country clear as day we got
him chris's account had two factors so
the only possible way you think they got
in is they got into his phone as well
i don't know how that's possible i mean
they were using a vpn the recovery
number phone number to recover the
christian's account was a russian phone
number that's when we realized christian
had admin access the leak occurred
through christian's gmail account the
gmail account was associated with the
quarter crew login the hackers were able
to breach our system without triggering
any alarms or any security at that point
they had free reign to do whatever they
wanted with our youtube channel there's
something in progress right now because
it's just it's updating videos it's safe
to navigate away wait before making
another bulk update on the videos page
there is a ongoing status bar that says
updating videos wait before making
another bulk update we're at a stage
right now where we don't know if it's
youtube or the people hacking there's
this like progress bar of like this bulk
update happening on our channel i think
i think they're privating all of our
videos if not deleting all of our videos
what should we tell the team to do right
now they'll need to log out of
everything else on their computers but
if you're signed into anything
corridor digital on your phone or your
computer sign up log out of everything
luckily you know i've already been
hacked it's no big deal i have
two-factor authentication for everything
i am going head-for-head with the
russians right now i have to change
every single login and password that
this company has ever created if i don't
change all these passwords right now we
could very well get hacked again i'm
going to change the crew channel
password now uh we need a new password
nico here's a password we'll never
forget
corridor crew password xx quarter crew
xxx
one two three four actually i was
thinking
q
and if you can guess it then it'll prove
that it's not a secure password go
asdf1234
almost
i think i got it
honestly big scheme of things it's like
the gentlest reminder to like make sure
your security is good just go back on
private the videos change the icon and
change you know change the name of the
channel and like delete the channel and
like now we're like out of revenue for
like the next five days like that would
suck
the corridor crew we've removed your
channel from youtube literally if you if
you click on it right now it just goes
to this monkey holding the magnifying
glass the account's been terminated
because of a violation of blah blah
which is the worst violation there is
thanks michael saylor you little monkey
this might be one of the few times we'll
ever google search corridor crew and not
be able to click on anything even though
the channel was secured we had already
informed youtube of the hack and this is
their system doing its job by completely
terminating the channel to fix the
channel it could take their team
anywhere from one to three days we don't
have
one to three days we've never missed a
saturday upload of react and if we do
then the hackers win
we decide that the best thing to do is
to upload react on thursday as we do
every week at least our website
subscribers would not feel the effect of
this breach oh okay so at least we still
get the react this weekend on the
website i don't think that a single
react has been missed for like
the three and a half years that it's
been running so i guess we technically
have never missed a react 6 30 rolls
around and i refresh the page it's that
darn monkey man taunting me again saying
it done in this business job i'm leaving
work at 6 30 thinking we still don't
have the channel back
day two of the hack the channel still
does not exist but we are pressing on
just like we normally would what kind of
person does this type of thing i mean
there's a couple of different things one
is it's just people looking for a
challenge you know looking for
vulnerabilities people just testing
their skill the same way that you know
you guys will do one render and then
another rendering you you're constantly
challenging yourself other times it's
monetary gain you know if you can uh
take over a channel broadcast crypto
purchasing then obviously there's the
monetary gains side of things at the end
of the day we're not going to know who
did the hack 6 30 pm comes around and i
make the call we're we're not uploading
our videos because we don't have a
channel saturday comes around we don't
have a channel sunday comes around we
don't have a channel so we all arrive
for the monday morning meeting and
that's when jake tells us as of three
hours ago they finished recovering
everything
and now we have the channel back all in
all corridor crew was completely
unresponsive for five days and we lost
tens of thousands of dollars in that
period of time you know fortunately the
website did what it needed to do one of
the mottos or mantras of us of ours
while creating this website was what if
youtube disappeared tomorrow even though
we were in the dark a little bit about
if we were going to upload on our normal
youtube schedule we weren't going to
miss a beat on quarterdigital.com those
of you who are on this website
essentially sponsoring us by subscribing
and being a part of this community you
make it possible for us to weather these
kinds of storms to continue to produce
the things that we love and we hope that
you love without that things would have
been a lot scarier and a lot darker that
was the light at the end of the tunnel
so if you haven't already head over to
corridordigital.com or download the app
it truly is the best way to support what
we do and of course with every
membership you not only get early access
to everything we post on youtube you
also get exclusive shows like the crew
cuts vlogs our dungeons and dragon show
son of a dungeon with season 2 coming
mid-september and extended react
episodes with content we don't post on
youtube every sign up comes with a 14
day free trial so consider checking it
out welcome back to crew cuts we've got
an exciting episode for you today but
first let's just take a moment
oh and enjoy the nature
[Music]
so we are back on location this week